So our goal is to write code now, that computes
the formula that we worked out earlier. Then we want to compute
the rank, for each page. The thing that we're going to do,
instead of using this recursive definition, we're going to write a loop,
that goes through the time steps, and we're going to figure out
how many time steps we want. The more time steps, the
more accurate rankings we'll have, but the longer it will take.
So we'll just pick a value for the maximum number of
time steps, and we'll make our loops go through
those steps, computing these equations. So let's work out the
code to do that. So now that we've got the
graph. All that's left to do is figure out how
to use it, to compute the page ranks. So to
do that, we'll make a procedure called compute_ranks. It takes
as input, a graph that gives the link structure. So,
as an example we have our graph that has the
URLs, and each URL, followed by the link of pages that it links to. And this is
the graph that was produced by our crawler, and
crawLweb produced as outputs, a graph as well as
an index. We're going to use the graph as
the input to compute_ranks. So the output from compute_ranks,
will be a dictionary, giving for each URL, the
Urank, the ranking that we compute using our formula.
And, the higher the rank, the better. And, what
we're going to do once we have those ranks, and this
last part is going to be left as a homework
assignment for you. We're going to instead of having just look
up, we're going to have lookup_best. And lookup_best will take
three inputs. It will take the keyword we're looking for.
It will also take the index that came from the
crawl, and it will also take the ranks, and from
those three inputs, the index will give us all
the pages that contain the keyword, and then what lookup_best
will do is, use the ranks to find the
highest ranked page, and give that as the output. So
once we've done that, you'll have a complete search
engine. You'll have a crawler that starts from a seed,
finds pages, produces an index, produces a graph. That
graph is the input to compute_ranks, compute_ranks uses our page
ranking algorithm to figure out the pages that
are most popular. And then lookup_best takes the graph
as input, the index as input, and the keyword,
finds the pages that contain that keyword, and identifies
the one that's best, using the ranks. So that's
what you'll have after the homework of this unit.
We're going to finish compute_ranks now, and leave it up
to you to define lookup_best as a homework question.